good morning John so as you may have
noticed I like to do all the jobs VidCon
is coming up at the end of this month
lizzie bennet
just passed fifty thousand subscribers
scishow and crash course Andrew the fail
and eco geek and dftba records it's a
long list and sometimes people ask me
Hank how do you do so much stuff you
must have some excellent productivity
tips and yes I do I'm like apparently
everyone else I put my pants on two legs
at a time I've developed a faster way of
tying my shoes and also a faster and
more efficient way to ambulate I predict
within the next five years
everyone will be walking like this
people also spend a huge amount of time
eating and I've stopped doing that and
instead I just ingest 2,000 calories of
muscle milk in one sitting this is also
dramatically decreased the amount of
time that I spend pooping though it has
really increased the amount of time I
spend peeing which is why I've developed
this special desk check did you see that
you know from what's up/ok
another tip I get my medical procedures
in bulk hang out while giving a girl
kaboom also I get my computer to do work
for me for example I wrote a script that
goes to Amazon for me so I don't have to
do it and orders more muscles like
otherwise I'd spend a huge amount of
time just ordering muscle milk and Al's
wrote a script that emails my wife
romantic messages on important holidays
Zenor was really busy so I didn't write
the whole program it's based on a
Russian spam writing algorithms an
example of one for my last anniversary I
am very loved Katherine it is more than
your life is at its best when I have
seen you to comply your hair as you can
see is in no need of introduction
because of course it has no business
with you my duty as your man is now do
you want to be your friend for all of
the rest of viagra but my biggest tip
for all of you is instead of actually
doing things just imagine doing fun
things that way you can get the maximum
amount of stuff done well in the end
making sure that you never really ever
do anything yes kidding
I don't like muscle milk God Michael
drinks that stuff it's separable for
serious I do do a lot of stuff and I am
pretty serious about you know making
sure that I use my time productively
there's a thing on my computer called
rescue time it like tracks where and
what I do while I'm on my computer and
it's great it's kind of hilarious
because it's always like you spread
so much time on YouTube and I'm like
yeah but that's my job rescue time that
leads to another point about how I have
the Ausmus job ever I work a lot because
work is more like a hobby for me that's
where a lot of this like all the jobs do
lots of different projects thing comes
from for me I just like making things
it's one of the things that makes me
excited about life I was about to say
that you know I could be more productive
because I have helped VidCon has a whole
team Carver and Monica and Jenny and
Lindsay dftba records has Alan and Sam
and Kristen and then with scishow and
crash course we got a whole team I'd
love to introduce you to them sometime
everybody they're great but I think
that's one of the things that I learned
from this project with you John is that
I like to collaborate with people and no
none of them are as good of the
collaborator as you are still number one
but I like to do projects I like to
collaborate I like to be on a team it's
like sports except you're actually doing
something let me be the first to say
what works for me in terms of
productivity is not gonna work for
everybody
I don't like like rigid micro manage
schedules I like to let my sort of like
internal stress level decide what I'm
gonna work on that day if I get really
busy and I freak out just you know flip
over Emma Stone's eyeball and the funny
thing is flipping over Emma Stone's
eyeball for me is work so thanks to
everybody John I'll see you on Tuesday
did you see that you haven't got spit
all over the screen